[Musique]
je suis venu effectivement la rencontre
de ce club
ici à la montagne club les chrysanthèmes
qui peuplent soleil ici à la montagne
tout simplement pourquoi parce que
bientôt je vais travailler avec les
services du département avec les élus
pour lancer une belle opération qui sera
un plan pour les seniors de la réunion
vous avez aujourd'hui les personnes
âgées de plus de 60 ans sont en
augmentation et on aura un doublement de
la population donc de plus de 60 ans il
nous convient à nos hommes politiques au
département comme ailleurs de savoir
comment nous allons accueillir cette
population de plus de 60 ans sur le
territoire comment nous allons engager
des actions pour venir en aide à ces
populations en termes de logement
d'adaptation de logements en termes
d'activités associatives en termes de
d'animation et tout cela me fait dire
que nous devons anticiper au département
et le plan senior
ce sera un travail partenarial
bien sûr département services de l'état
mais aussi tous les partenaires comme la
caf la sécurité sociale et bien d'autres
partenaires
la mairesse et d'autres encore avec
lesquels nous allons travailler pour
justement anticiper sur le
vieillissement de la population
[Musique]